[Music]  move over Kim K Nicki Minaj may be the  new queen of paper magazine yes  absolutely and I'll wear that title  proudly to the rapper gets very  provocative posing for the mags break  the internet edition titled  menage-a-trois next to three versions of  herself on cinema cinema Nicki is  literally filling on herself in a series  of racy ensembles there's a blonde Nicki  grabbing a black haired and nearly  topless version of Minaj then there's  another version of the rapper bits over  with long blonde hair in between her  legs love your curves and squeeze your  curves and rub it in everyone's face  after the starships hitmaker shared the  cover on Instagram Kim Kardashian liked  and commented on the not-safe-for-work  pic with three fire emojis I love that  you